bonjour à vous tous le maire de
fraîcheur est avec nous en studio
bonjour marcellin nadeau bonjour
bertrand krug bon toujours à toutes les
auditrices et tous les auditeurs de
martinique combien la radio revenons
quelques minutes sur la vive altercation
qui a marqué avant-hier la manifestation
traditionnelle de célébration du 22 mai
par un collectif de plusieurs
organisations politiques et syndicales
pour aller vite on va dire plus ou moins
proche du grand semblait alors ça se
passe en un lieu situé entre saint
pierre et le prêcheur alors je rassure
tout le monde nous n'allons pas y passer
l'émission en entier 1 mais mais tout de
même marcellin nadeau
c'est vrai nous vous avons entendus hier
vous déclaré surpris d'avoir été cité en
tant que maire dans une rédaction
d'alfred marie-jeanne suite à cet
incident cependant bertrand cambuse il
un des protagonistes premier secrétaire
général de la cstm ne vous est pas
totalement inconnu il avait été candidat
à une élection cantonale me semble-t-il
il y a plusieurs années au diamant sous
la bannière du modemas alors serait-il
toujours dans votre giron peut-être même
du côté de nou pé plat le mouvement que
vous animez depuis quelques temps et du
coup peut-être finalement ne seriez-vous
pas totalement étranger à son coup de
force de mardi au nom de la mémoire de
marc pulvar on implante théories
complotistes là non il n'y a aucun
complot entre il ya quelque temps ce qui
conduisit et nous d'ailleurs je veux
rappeler que bertrand bungie a peut-être
été effectivement est peut-être un
sympathisant notre mouvance politique
mais un point c'est chez nous c'est que
lors du mans on a des fonctions
syndicales nous respectons
l'indépendance des syndicats et il est
hors de question pour nous de nous
immiscer dans le fonctionnement d'un
syndicat qu'il soit fût-il celui que
dirige bien tant qu'on quand mozilla 7e
mais ce qu'il faut préciser quand même
c'est que nous n'avons rien à voir dans
cette histoire au contraire la septième
comme le minent ces deux organisations
appartiennent à un collectif qui le cap
et 22 mai et qui organise d'ailleurs
depuis nonino cette cérémonie
veut dire politique au doigt de
l'habitation du chant donc sur le
territoire de saint pierre à sainte
philomène et lorsque nous avons décidé
avec le maire de saint-pierre d'essayer
d'organiser une commémoration commune à
nos deux villes autour de la figure de
l'esclave romain nous l'avons décidé
justement pris en compte cette donnée là
pour dire que nous commençons après
justement la fin de cette manifestation
donc elle n'a strictement rien à voir
avec nous d'ailleurs la manifestation
celle de fraîcheur et saint piat
s'appelait bien les résistances à l'
esclavage de l'afrique aux amériques
autour de la figure de l'esclave au
robin et nous n'avons rien avant et je
dois dire aussi au passage que ça n'est
pas la première fois bon là
effectivement il ya eu je veux dire un
écho médiatique mais ça n'est pas la
première fois que depuis deux ans
qu'alfred marie jeanne se laisse aller à
ce type de dérapage incontrôlé
interpellant le meilleur de prêcheurs
extra je veux simplement dire le
président de l'exécutif de la ctm a
déclaré que l'amitié avec la ville du
prêcheur est également terminons mais
avant-hier l'amitié entre la ville de
fraîcheur et de marges a dit j diriger
la collectivité majeur martiniquaise
cette collectivité doit du respect à
toutes les collectivités martiniquaise
quelles qu'elles soient toutes les
communes martiniquaise quelles qu'elles
soient à toutes les martiniquaises et
tous les martiniquais quel qu'il soit
les prêts je tenais les prochains le
choix comme les martiniquais ont choisi
les dirigeants de la ctm
ils ont le choix de choisir les élus du
prêcheur c'est leur choix démocratique
et on leur doit du respect on doit du
respect à leur dignité en doit leur
droit du losc en tant que contribuable
martiniquais et moi je veux dire que je
trouve regrettable que on est ce type de
d'événements dans le cadre du 22 mai
mais en nous semblait le 22 mai c'est
l'occasion de rassemblements
est ce que je demande par contre pour ne
pas faire diversion différencions il
faudrait pris le répondre concrètement
par contre sur la question du lieu de la
commémoration officielle de n2 mais il
n'est pas normal que dans ce pays bien
sûr chacun peut commémorer le 22 mai
chez lui dans son quartier dans sa
commune et je félicite d'ailleurs tous
les maires qui font ce travail de
mémoire fondamentale mais imaginez un
seul instant que en france pour le 14
juillet il n'y aucune commémoration
officielle à paris comment se fait-il
que nous n'ayons pas de commémoration
officielle de 22 mai au prêcheur et à
saint-pierre et jeunes au jeu je me
félicite d'ailleurs que s'agissant de
septembre 1870 qu'il y ait une
commémoration officielle à
rivière-pilote ou los bravos
mais ça qui est bon pour rivière-pilote
bon pou échecs ses pieds tout marc
fesneau nadeau dernière question à ce
sujet qu'est ce que cet incident dit de
l'état des relations entre les deux
camps pour aller vite du souverainisme
martinique est en tout cas une chose est
sûre cela ne lui fait pas bonne presse
non mais moi je crois que nous sommes
voulons sortir de ces logiques là moi je
crois que il faut reposer les problèmes
fondamentaux de ce temps naturellement
d'observer en tant que maire
manille tellement barré bougies ray j'ai
tellement de de choses à faire dans
l'intérêt de la population ils tous les
problèmes que nous avons martinique les
sargasses le dcsp le transport la
pollution
le chômage le logement le panier de
bagues et a fait qu'avec encore tout au
tout au tout les temps toute la sainte
journée quand guy bach a fini et même le
22 mai nous parfois ça dure depuis les
dernières municipales on ne joue pas
juste 7 7
il faut sur cette fâcherie en feu entre
le se focalise là éliminés notables en
tirer ça nous a dit non pas grâce à kobe
personnes il est effectivement deux gros
cons qui structure le paysage politique
martiniquais nous appelons justement à
la concordera la concorde matic au débat
ça veut pas dire qu'il ferait on doit
trouver dans une sorte d'unanimisme mais
ça veut dire qu'ils font un espace
démocratique apaisée entre guillemets
avec beaucoup de guillemets civilisé où
on échangeront des bas des grandes
problématiques concernant ce peuple
débattons discutons travaillant pour le
peuple
et arrêtons ces cancans qui relève en
fait d'une sorte de compétition pour la
conquête des places et aider plat de
lentilles alors les prix se tiennent et
les prochains sont la préoccupation des
l'art la saison des pluies est entamée
ça y est le mois dernier il ya eu une
mission de la direction générale de la
sécurité civile et de la gestion des
crises la dgs cgc voilà quand est-ce que
vous aurez le retour en fait ils sont
venus pourquoi ces techniciens
je crois qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'ingénieurs c'est ça qui est ça dès
qu'il ya eu deux missions 20
volcanologues et puis il ya eu deux
missions une première mission donc
effectivement de cette grande direction
domitia l'intérieur français à la
demande du préfet avec un universitaire
et des responsables de cette direction
est bon on a pas encore on retourne à
quelques éléments seulement nous
attendons le retour de cette mission là
par contre nous avons déjà quelques
éléments de retour s'agissant de la
deuxième mission qui était mené par un
des ingénieurs de de l'onef spécialiste
de ces questions alors effectivement il
ya et surtout quelles dispositions
prendre la forme et jusqu'à l'orée de la
saison
plusieurs échéances à envisager à très
court terme effectivement je pense qu'il
ya travail de curage à faire quand on
parle de curage et effectivement le fait
d'extraire des matériaux du lit de la
rivière mais aussi c'est la nécessité de
faire du confortement des berges
bon ce ne sera pas un confortement
définitif on n'aura pas le temps de
faire de manière durable somme de choses
mais il ya un certain nombre de
deux mesures à prendre de de
confortement d'aménagement en fait on va
dire au provisoire parler vite des
belges
effectivement je pense que il faut le
faire avant bon construits avant les
conclusions données
et puis aussi bon le système d' alerte
que nous allons effectivement nous avons
déjà amélioré que nous allons avec
l'état d'ailleurs améliorer encore non
je crois que nous travaillons et c'est
vrai que l'arrivée de la saison des
pluies mais me préoccupe vraiment et je
veux faire tout bon c'est vrai que nous
bénéficions quand même d'une étroite
collaboration des ses différents
services de l'état nous voulons faire
tout pour que nous soyons dans soit à
peu près pour cette saison des pluies
dans l'intérêt de la population de
pression très rapidement vous venez de
signer une convention de coopération
avec la ville haïtienne de deux pilotes
un peu plus de 30000 habitants me
semble-t-il une terre de café mais enfin
pourquoi cette ville de turquie et pas
d'ailleurs la plus connue d'haïti enfin
il ya un certain nombre de similitudes
cd pas vraiment la population du canton
prend une ville comme prenez la ville de
carrefour qui a une coupe et à chaque
haïti elle avait eu deux cas font c'est
presque et au delà la population de la
martinique
donc on ne peut pas comparer haïti à la
martinique donc c'est soit de 30000
effectivement nous sommes une commune de
1600 habitants beau pour 30000 mais ce
qui nous caractérise ces deux communes
c'est que nous sommes des territoires
agricoles
c'est que nous sommes en zone de
montagne c'est que nous avons aussi dire
préoccupations en matière de protection
de l'environnement et je crois que tout
cela doit nous unir dans l'esprit de la
coopération il ne s'agit pas d'aller
aider
on sort de la logique de l'aide ou
donner des leçons il s'agit bien pour
nous de du co développement de la
coopération des échanges et je crois que
nous avons apportées ici comme ait ya
beaucoup à nous apporter
et c'est dans cette philosophie là que
nous voulons effectivement coopérer avec
haïti et d'ailleurs nous avons dans nos
murs je veux dire nationale commune à la
fois le maire de chat et le député de la
circonscription de chat et les choses se
passent très bien sont très contents ils
étaient très contents de participer à
notre fête des agriculteurs mais il faut
dire aussi que avec pour l'instant nous
sommes sur le premier axe qui est celui
de l'eau avec notamment l'office de
l'eau en un deuxième axe à venir avec l'
agence d'urbanisme de la martinique et
bien sûr il ya toujours avec nous et la
caraïbe et puis nous aurons troisième
axe avec shut grand gosier en lance à
galets la désirade et et grembert à
dominique sur la création de la mer et
de la pêche
merci marcellin nadeau maire du prêcheur
d'avoir participé à ça au caddie bonne
journée à tous